Okay.
We're talking about acid derivatives,
uh,
where we started last time talking about ACL insertions,
although I'm not sure I mentioned the term.
And then about reactivity at the position adjacent to carbon eels,
Alpha reactivity and condensation reactions,
which are related to that,
which are chapters 18 and 19 in the Jones tax.
So a cell insertion is to put an atom in the bond between the r and the carbonyl
group,
the ACL group.
So you just moved the,
our aside and put x in there.
Okay.
So x can be an oxygen,
uh,
the buyer villiger reaction of ketones.
It can be,
uh,
an Nh group.
So you can make an amine from a key tone.
It can be a ch two group,
so you from which,
uh,
inserted into the carboxylic acid.
So in the first case,
you get a ketone transformed to an Ester in the second case of ketone
transformed to a mid,
in the third case,
it's an acid,
goes to an acid,
but it's an asset that's longer by one carbon.
Can you think of any other ways of having an acid and making an acid that's
longer by one carbon?
It has to be sort of a roundabout way.
You could go from the acid to the alcohol,
right
from the alcohol to the haylight.
Now you've got something you can make reactive.
It's reactive in itself.
The Halo lied.
You could displace it with a carbon nucleophile that would add one carbon to the
chain.
So it could be CN,
right?
And then we know you can hydrolyze Sia and to make a carboxylic acid.
So that would be one one unit longer.
Or once you have the Alk Hill haylight you can make it into a grin are reagent
or an Kia lithium.
And they had CO2,
which is a carboxylic acid.
Again,
one way.
So there are many ways,
as we said last time to skin the cat.
But one way is this aren't I stared procedure,
which,
which gives good yields.
So we starting to talk about the buyer villiger a reaction last time.
And um,
I'm going to put it on the right some more on the board here with this.
No,
it's this one.
Okay.
So as we said last time,
the buyer Villinger reaction hopes this is,
I thought I,
yeah,
it's supposed to turn that projector off.
MMM.
I think I'll just
turn it off
and we'll use the side ones for the rest of the,
okay.
So the buyer Villinger reaction as we said,
starts with a key tone.
Yeah.
And reacts with that.
Okay.
Per Roxie acid.
Which is of course an acid.
It's got a PK,
I think about seven or something like that.
So we can get the anti in here.
Okay.
We could add the acid and make the,
the analog of a Hemi Quito.
But,
uh,
instead
we don't have a leaving group here that we can leave.
It looks like the only leaving group is that,
but there's a fancy way to do it,
which is this can make these electrons of high energy so we can use those
electrons.
Okay.
To displace the leaving group.
So now we have Si.
Oh,
our prime.
are,
okay.
So we've inserted that oxygen between the originally ACL carbon and the,
our group.
So we have an Ester.
Yeah.
Plus,
of course,
the carboxylic acid,
which was a good leaving group.
Yeah.
And I ended the carboxylic acid.
Now,
uh,
I indicated here that we had different art groups or could have different r
groups are in our prime.
The question obviously arises of which one,
uh,
which one migrates which Esther do you get?
Uh,
now this has,
this is called migratory aptitude.
Yeah.
And it comes in a reasonable order.
H
tertiary,
radical secondary,
primary
and c h three.
But I didn't tell you whether this is increasing or decreasing in migratory
aptitude.
So what is the group that shifts?
Is that a cat ion or radical or an an eye on,
what am I showing my curve
when our moves over?
Does it move without electrons with one electron or with a pair of electrons
with a pair of electrons.
So it's r minus that moves.
Okay.
At least it's a height.
It's a myth.
I'd or an and shift.
When you say like the Meth,
I'd shift now.
So do you think methyl is the best or the worst?
That shifting say,
compared with a tertiary,
which should be the best?
Suppose that were a cad ion on that we're shifting,
which would be best?
Well,
yeah.
What do you think?
Which is the best cat?
[inaudible] methyl.
A primary.
A secondary.
A tertiary.
Okay.
Yeah,
tertiary.
So if it's just the opposite with an ions,
right?
So if it's an an eye on the shifting,
then one would predict that methyl would be the thing that would be easiest to
shift and tertiary would be the hardest.
But in fact h is better than this and this is better.
Better,
better,
right?
So it's not the best.
And I on that shifts,
it's the best cat die on the shifts.
Doesn't that seem curious?
But the reason is that it doesn't break completely away to become our minus,
right?
It's electrons
which have been boosted and energy by having this charge next door are being
shared with sigma star here.
Right.
So in fact,
those electrons have to be given to something else in order for the
rearrangement to take place.
If it were an alcaide shift in which they are pulled away to become an ion and
then attacked sigma star,
then the best anti and would do it.
But that's not the way it goes.
It's exactly the opposite because it actually is giving up electrons in the
process of shifting.
These electrons are being given the sigma star,
so it's the best cat on migrates fast,
fastest,
which seems sort of funny when you say that it's an alcaide shift.
Okay.
Uh,
one other feature is that if you have,
um,
if the group that's migrating
is Kyrell,
then since you're just moving these electrons over,
it's not any kind of backside attack.
So the are in the product.
We'll retain stereochemistry.
Okay.
This is the buyer villiger reaction.
So that inserts and oxygen.
Then we said that the Beckman Rearrangement,
uh,
notice that these are old.
Remember the buyer villiger was done at the same time that Gomberg was there.
Essentially 1900,
roughly.
The Beckman rearrangement is 1886.
This was done by,
uh,
one of the few organic chemists who was also a physical chemist backed bond.
He invented a very,
very sensitive thermometer as well and worked in the same,
uh,
department with Austin,
all whom we mentioned before.
But the,
uh,
the back of Henri rearrangement puts a nitrogen in,
so it starts with a key town
like cyclohexanone and inserts a nitrogen.
Okay.
And the bond between carbon and oxygen and the reagent that does it.
Is hydroxyl mean
okay.
And then treated with acid.
So we already talked about what a means do with ketones.
They give him means and it's especially good to do.
Yeah.
For a means you remember that have unshared pairs that are interacting
unfavorably.
Yeah.
So you'll lose water and generate what's called an
yeah.
Now the backbone rearrangement happens when this is treated with strong acid.
You could imagine it protonated and the nitrogen,
it probably does that,
but one it does it,
it comes off again.
But it can protonate the oxygen as well.
No.
And now we have the leaving group,
but in plus doesn't look like us or such a very good cad ion.
So in fact,
what you use is the electrons here.
These electrons shift up.
So it's very much likely,
uh,
r minus R R plus if you wish shift in that case.
Oops.
Sorry.
Some part of me that this is the C.
Alright.
It explicitly,
and we have the on here.
All right.
Uh,
double bond here.
Yeah.
And notice that since these electrons left this carbon,
there should be a positive charge on this carbon in the formula.
All right.
Uh,
so since this is done with water resin,
we can put water on there.
Well,
actually,
let me draw a resonance structure of this first.
Uh,
notice that,
uh,
it's hard to pull these electrons away to leave this,
what would appear to be a vinyl cad ion,
right?
But remember that the nitrogen has a pair of electrons in its Pi system.
Uh,
me just stuck on this.
I got that right.
Yeah.
It's got another pair of electrons.
These electrons are displacing this.
So they're coming again backside to that orbital.
But there's another pair of electrons on the nitrogen.
And at the same time that these electrons are leaving from this carbon,
these electrons can go toward that carbon.
And if that happens,
we got a resonance structure of this thing.
Okay.
Which has the positive charge.
Oh,
on the nitrogen.
Right.
So it's not unstable as you might've thought,
but any rate when we add water,
okay,
I lose a proton,
we can get this,
which is of course related Al Lily,
Chloe.
If we just shift the Proton.
Okay,
so this,
I'm good.
So we've indeed inserted n h into the carbon eel to Alpha carbon bond.
Incidentally,
this particular bean,
this particular lactone a lactone
lactam.
Pardon me?
A lactone is a cyclical Esther.
I'll walk town is a sick lick Amin or a mid right.
And this particular one is called caprolactam.
Yeah.
And it's of some commercial interest because if you hydrolyze it,
it becomes this amine.
All
right.
Which of course can Sciflies the amine conform in the mid with the Coh,
but it can also form polymers where the amine attacks the,
the a carboxylic acid of another molecule.
So instead of a ring one can then get a chain and you can get a very,
very long chain.
This is called nylon polymer.
All right?
If this way
it's called nylon six.
Yeah.
So the six means that there are six carbons in the chain between the amid
groups.
Okay.
Now again,
we could wonder in a,
in a case where we have different ours here,
which are migrates,
that is which one gets next to the nitrogen.
Okay.
Now one might think that would be something like this up here where the best cat
ion would move because it's electrons are being shared with the sigma star who's
that's allowing the water to leave.
But it's actually not that because you'll notice there are two different isomers
of oxy hymns.
Okay.
And if you're careful,
you can separate them.
And it turns out that in this one are migrates,
but in this one,
our prime migrates,
which doesn't surprise you because it's a backside attack cause displacement of
the water.
So it inserts the nitrogen inserts in the anti bond.
The one that's,
yeah,
the one that's away from the h?
Yes.
Okay.
So that's the backbone rearrangement.
And then the art,
I stare a reaction,
which is up the whole model allegation,
the one that makes the,
I'm Allison one year longer.
Okay,
so you have a carboxylic acid
and insert c h two
in this bond.
And the way that one goes is first to react with soc all to what will that do to
the acid SOCL to remember that reagent switches,
the wage up for seal replaces all h with cl,
the same as it does in Roa h so we have an acid chloride.
Yeah.
And now nuclear files can,
I can,
uh,
do association dissociation and displace the chloride.
And the particular nucleophile that's used in this case is called die a zone
methane.
Yeah.
It's a very poisonous and unstable compound.
It's a good idea not to work with it.
It's one of these interesting molecules that you can't draw a Lewis structure
without putting in charge in it,
which is sort of a tip that it might be reactive,
but you can draw not only that resonance structure,
but also this one.
Yeah.
The nitrogen in the middle has to be
positive,
but the negative charge can be written on either end of the molecule.
It's probably better to put it on nitrogen that to put it on carbon.
But the reactivity is of the carbon.
So this is that these are the electrons that come up and then,
okay,
lost again.
So substitution at the ACL carbon as we've been speaking about.
So now we have,
uh,
c h two n plus triple bond,
which loses a proton
to give r
o c h and to,
uh,
okay,
I'll draw it this way
if I had done it right.
Uh,
did I do it took those electrons in there?
Yep.
Okay,
good.
Uh,
yeah.
Plus minus.
Okay.
Which is called a diease.
Oh,
ketone.
No,
it doesn't surprise you that dies.
Oh,
ketones when heated
and it's often done in the presence of silver
lose nitrogen.
Can you give an unusual compound?
Okay.
Because there's just a same,
just to bonds to that hydrogen to that carbon.
It's like a car being,
so it has a vacant orbital.
Yeah.
And An unshared pair.
All right.
And now you can see how we're set up for the rearrangement.
These electrons can shift
just as they did in the Beckman rearrangement,
just as they did in the,
in the buyer villiger reaction.
Right.
Which would,
but at the same time,
these electrons.
Okay.
Then come here
to make a double
bond.
So we have c double bond,
o
double bond,
c,
h,
R.
Right.
And notice that this,
okay,
if we trace through this carbon here
became this carbon
and this carbon
became a,
this carbon
and it's now this carbon.
Yeah,
so we inserted that carbon between the carbonyl carbon and the r group.
Okay.
Now we've seen this kind of compound before.
It's an acid derivative.
It's a key team.
Yeah.
So it can add water,
as we've discussed before,
to give R,
which accomplishes what we wanted to do.
Wait
c h two now because of the age from the water.
Okay,
so that's the aren't I stared of procedure,
which LinkedIn's a carboxylic acid by one unit.
Second,
I want to speak a little bit about the rest of the stuff we're going to talk
about with acid derivatives is reaction that the Alpha position that is making
an an eye on at the Alpha position and using that.
So like an [inaudible].
But first we should look at the,
at the acidity of these compounds.
Uh,
so I'll just use the slide to talk about that.
Okay,
so the PKA of acid aldehyde is 17,
right?
A acetone,
we talked about this before,
is slightly more acidic.
That is the,
the anti,
any or part,
probably slightly less acidic,
the anti and isn't quite as stable.
19 to two a or two orders of magnitude in the equilibrium constant.
Okay.
Now the Ester is another five orders of magnitude less acidic,
right?
The equilibrium constant is 10 to the fifth smaller.
Why is it that the ester forms is less prone to form the anti and by losing that
Red Proton than a ketone is,
okay,
I could make the opposite argument.
I could say oxygen is electron withdrawing,
which should make
it easy to form an an eye on.
So there must be something else that goes in the opposite direction that's even
more important.
What is it,
Roy?
What allows you to form?
That's right.
What allows you to form the anti and at this position is it's in these cases,
it's that stabilization by mixing with the Lumo Pi Star.
But in this case,
the Luba was always already being used to stabilize the electrons of the oxygen.
In fact,
you could make the same argument here in terms of hyper conjugation,
that the Pi Star here is being used to stabilize the electrons in a ch bond,
right?
So when those,
when that a vacant orbital,
the Pi Star mixes with the occupied orbital,
whether it's ch bond or even higher than the unshared pair of oxygen,
then they mix and the vacant orbital becomes higher and less able to stabilize
the Ani and on the carbon here.
Right?
So that,
that's a clear understood.
Now,
notice that a cyanide group,
as we've said before,
I so called night trial,
has much the same character as a carbon eel.
In fact,
this has the same,
uh,
this has the same acidity as the Esther does.
Okay.
Now,
in an amid,
so this amid has a PK of 18.
Does that make sense to you?
What would you have predicted?
Ayesha?
Yes.
If,
uh,
if the Aldehyde is here,
when you have a,
an unsure that when you have a bond next door,
you get a little bit of,
of,
uh,
raising the vacant orbital,
right?
So it's not so good.
Unshared pair on oxygen is even more important and makes it a lot of civic.
What would you expect if I,
instead of oxygen here,
if I had nitrogen?
How about it's unshared?
Pair?
Yeah.
Huh.
You got everything right except the periodic table,
right?
Nitrogen comes before oxygen.
So nitrogen has less nuclear charge than oxygen.
So it's unshared is higher in energy.
So what would you expect would he makes even more with Pi Star?
Pi Star would go up even more and it should be,
uh,
it should be less acidic.
It should be greater than 24.
And the reason is that that's not what ionizes what?
Ionizes is a hydrogen from the nitrogen.
So it's like the amid is a little bit like a carboxylic acid,
so it's not comparable with these others actually.
Right.
But if you put to our groups on the nitrogen so it doesn't have a hydrogen,
it can lose then.
Indeed it's less acidic than the Ester,
which is what you predicted once you get the periodic table.
Right.
Okay.
Now you can do even better if you have two carbon eels.
So notice that all of these are weaker acids than water,
right?
So if you put them in with hydroxide,
the equilibrium will have the proton on them,
not on the water.
Right?
So if you can,
especially in the cases up here,
they're close enough to water,
water's about 1615 0.7 they're close enough that you get an that there is some
anti entity equilibrium,
a significant amount.
So you can do reactions with it.
Right?
But mostly it's not in that form.
Mostly it's in the protonated form.
But if you have two carbon eels,
then it becomes quite acidic.
And we spoke before when we were talking about the myths are Nobu reaction about
active methylene compounds,
methylene group,
ch two groups that are adjacent that are activated by two adjacent Pi Star or
but also that then they become much more acidic.
This one has a pka of five.
Right?
And if we have two methyl groups,
it's like going from here to here.
The PK is nine.
In fact,
it looks,
it looks uncannily good for that because if you've got two orders of magnitude
by putting on one methyl group from h to methyl here,
when you put on too,
you get forward,
there's a magnitude that's that's a spurious and how good at it,
uh,
how good the agreement is because you see,
if you put Esther on instead of the methyl as we did here,
Esther,
instead of methyl,
the PKA goes up as it did here.
But here it went up.
Five orders of magnitude here,
the acidity,
one up,
only two orders of magnitude.
So they're really not additive the way we were talking about,
but it's in the right direction,
right?
If you have to Esther's then it's another two orders of magnitude,
If you have nitrogen,
it goes up five orders of magnitude for the reason that we,
uh,
in fact,
compared to this one,
it went up seven orders of magnitude over here compared to the Esther to
nitrogen.
It went up six orders of magnitude.
So that one,
it looks reasonable,
right?
And finally,
uh,
if you have two night trial groups,
you can get,
uh,
you,
it's still quite acidic.
And notice that all of these are stronger acids than water,
except the one here which was deactivated by the unshared.
Pair the nitrogen,
right?
So if you put these with base,
they'll be in the,
an ionic form with hydroxide or alk oxide.
Okay.
So you can get these,
these anti ions from the simple compounds,
a small amount of equilibrium and strong base.
And for the double doubly activated compounds and high concentration,
if you put strong base in there,
in fact,
if you use an even stronger base like lithium die ice of propyl amid.
So amid remember as a confusing name because it means both the functional group,
c Double Bond,
o n,
but it also means a nitrogen.
And I,
and,
and you just have to know from context what you're talking about.
Okay.
So anyhow,
this is a nitrogen and I,
and so it's a strong anti and it's the,
the PKA is 36.
Right?
So if you were to take this one,
that,
that you don't get,
uh,
very good formation of pulling off this hydrogen,
the one that's much deactivated,
but you put it with this very strong base.
This one has a pka of 25,
but this one has a pka of 36.
So you have an equilibrium constant of 10 to the 11th favoring formation of the
Anti.
And so you could make a hundred percent essentially or,
uh,
just one part in 10 to the 11th.
Not that way if you,
uh,
if you use this very strong base.
So sometimes even,
uh,
these alpha and ions that are difficult to make,
if you use a really strong base,
you can get them all made.
Okay.
So,
so you can,
you have complete formation even of the amid insulate and not just a little bit
at equilibrium.
Okay.
And notice that it's a hindered base.
It's not die methyl or die.
Ethel,
it's die ice approachable and you want it to be hindered because otherwise this
h isn't so very easy to attack.
It would also be possible to attack the carbon yield group.
Pi Star had the nitrogen to this,
uh,
to this carbon and lose the other nitrogen.
You don't want that to happen.
So you use a hindered one that can only get at the hydrogen out there.
Okay?
Doesn't attack the insulate.
Uh,
now when you make these things,
you have a nuclear fill lake,
Alpha carbon.
That's why you make them so you can use carbon.
Remember in the ways we've talked about it mostly is an electrified while our
halogen,
uh,
the Pi Star of CW Bondo are low lumos.
Here's a carbon that's a high homo,
the unshared pair here on that kind of that Alpha carbon.
So this allows you then to form carbon carbon bonds with the other kinds,
the electrophilic carbons.
So by using that unshared pair to form a new bond.
Okay?
So let's look at some examples of that.
And it could be done either with acid or basic italicize via in the acid case
enal and in the base case in oh,
late an ion.
And you know how to do this,
I'm going to zip through it quickly.
So a proton comes in prototype.
In the acid catalyzed case,
you get this cat ion,
which is very stabilized because of the unshared pair on oxygen next door,
okay?
But that can lose a proton degenerate.
Any anal.
Okay.
But now in the case of hydrogen deuterium exchange,
it's interesting because if d comes up,
we can reverse the state the reactions.
We could have reversed it this way and put a proton on.
But if you have a Deuteron available,
then you can do it this way and go to there and now lose this a d plus.
And what we've done is exchange in the Alpha position,
hydrogen deuterium in place of hydrogen.
Okay?
So that's the acid catalyzed mechanism,
which doesn't surprise you.
You can also do it with basic analysis.
You can have bass come in and take the proton generating is an Ino late.
And I ion,
which of course has this resonance structure.
And now we have this as we had here,
a new,
uh,
nuclear fillic.
Yeah.
Nuclear affiliate carbon.
We also have a nuclear affiliate carbon here,
so we can in the Ino eight,
we could bring in a deuterated water and do it.
So you either acid or base allows you to exchange that,
uh,
those protons,
protons.
And if there's more than one proton,
you and that Alpha position,
you can exchange the others as well.
Now notice that you can also Ras Umyes in this way because if the other things
attached to this carbon,
we're a and B,
right?
You can go through exactly the same scheme,
acid or base,
but there's no configuration here.
So if the AE is,
if the H is in front of the plane here,
in this case,
when the h h plus comes back on,
it could come either from the front or from the back.
So,
so because this,
this thing is planar and this thing is plainer,
not chiral.
So,
so we've lost the memory of whether the thing was right or left handed so it
could come in from the back just as easily as from the front.
And then we Rasamayi wise,
uh,
so either by deuterium exchange or by randomization,
you can measure the rate at which ina latest formed and destroyed.
Okay.
You can also do Alpha halogenation and it's exactly the same scheme.
Again,
the only difference is once you get the anal or the analyte,
you react it with a halogen.
I've chosen to show IOD and here you can do it with chlorine or bromine as well.
So you can make an Alpha Halo Ketone,
right?
Nothing special here.
Now the product we made was an eye odo methyl ketone.
Right?
But we could also do the reaction with that.
Pull out if there's another hydrogen here.
We could,
we could,
uh,
we could do the acid catalyzed or the base catalyzed and get a dye.
I odo compound or can we,
in fact,
in this case,
only one of the pathways works.
And the reason is that the eye than the halogen is electron withdrawing,
right?
So it's deep.
It's makes,
gives positive charge to that carbon partial positive charge.
That means that if you want to up here,
you will be putting two positive charges next to one another.
Which isn't so great.
So in fact the acid catalyzed a pathway disappears after you've added the first.
And so you can put one in one I had in one chlorine,
one bromine,
but you can't put the second one in cause you can't with acid ketalysis get the
anal.
But if you have a positive charge there,
that's all the better for for uh,
for losing the Proton and getting the analytes.
So this is even faster.
The second one.
And what do you think happens next?
If you'd have another hydrogen there.
All right,
so there's the,
the base catalyzed of hearts,
but now you can do it with the dye iota methyl ketone and make a try.
Iota Messel ketone.
Okay,
so that's great.
What happens next with base?
Okay,
well there are no,
you can't have any more hydrogens on that one,
right?
So if you brought in hydroxide,
at this stage
it would attack the carbon eel.
Right?
But when it does that,
you could imagine the Eoh coming off again.
Although it's not such a good leaving group,
there's a better leaving group.
What's the better leaving group?
See I three with three halogens on the carbon.
It's a sufficiently good an iron that it can leave.
So we can unzip and that direction.
One of these association dissociation mechanisms and get that because the,
the PKA of,
of,
uh,
and then of course you want to transfer the Proton,
the PKA of,
of the,
uh,
Hci three is about 14,
so it's more acidic than water is.
Okay.
Now that's neat because that compound I odo form,
remember CHC all three as chloroform.
This is iota form,
but whereas chloroform is a colorless liquid,
I oto form is a yellow solid.
Right?
So this provided in the days before there was a Nmr,
like if you had a methyl ketone,
now you'd look for a methyl singlet,
right?
At a,
shifted down,
a shifted down field,
right?
At a certain position.
We know from Nmr how you'd identified it in the,
in the,
uh,
Carbon Nmr,
you'd look at a particular place,
right?
But in the days before,
there was spectroscopy to identify these things.
How would you know if you had a methyl ketone?
You reacted it in water with bass and I iodine and see whether you get a bright
yellow solid.
So this is a picture,
uh,
what you want is,
it isn't a,
I can't remember what just went chair and you can see here at two test tubes.
This one had a methyl ketone in it.
That one didn't.
This one has a yellow precipitate.
So that was a handy way of,
of uh,
of identifying methyl ketones in the days before spectroscopy.
Okay.
Now you can do it with,
you can do this Alpha halogenation with other,
uh,
carbon eel groups as well.
For example,
carboxylic acids.
So we've seen before that you could make a,
an acid chloride in this way.
And since I had it animated,
I decided to put it here so you can review it if you want to.
Right?
And that's how you get the acid chloride.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
but the,
one of the most,
uh,
charmingly named reactions is the hell Volart Zelinski reaction sometimes called
the HV z reaction.
But if you remember,
Ha Hell Volart Zelinski that's another one you can impress your,
your,
uh,
roommates with.
So it was held,
did it first and then volart and then Zelinski at about two year intervals,
a flanking 1885 so the hell ards Linsky,
I forget whether I've got this animated here,
are not involves PBR three
and bromine.
So the same way that SOCL to can,
can make an acid chloride from an acid.
So can PBR three in the,
so the HV z reaction,
a carboxylic acid
reacts with PBR three.
So you have the acid chloride or bromide.
Right.
But the acid bromide is very good at forming an anal.
And if you have bromine present,
yeah,
bromine can attack the,
a double bond because the cad ion will be stabilized with oxygen next door.
Oh.
So then when you lose the Proton,
okay.
You have Alpha Broman nation,
Roman nation adjacent.
Yeah.
So the carbon nailed group.
So this was easy to do because the [inaudible] acid bromide is good at forming
the,
uh,
anal.
But now it looks like you would need a store.
You need to keep making the acid bromide in order to,
to continue doing this reaction.
But in fact,
this could be catalytic.
Yeah.
Why couldn't it be catalytic?
Why do you need only a little bit?
You need a full mole of this of course,
because this can react with acid.
Uh,
uh,
I said,
yeah.
Okay.
So it displaces the bromide and we have br,
so the brominated product,
but now in the form of an acid and hydride.
Okay.
My different,
uh,
acid derivative.
But we also have br minus
yeah.
Which could attack here
and
then,
uh,
yeah,
then this comes,
let's see.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
what have I done wrong?
Oh,
I'm losing the,
yeah.
Uh,
right.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
back here,
because I didn't have the br,
I wasn't thinking,
right?
Yeah.
So now we have the acid plus the other product you can see is br.
So we traded,
which one was acid bromide in which one was carboxylic acid.
Right.
So now that's,
this can give this and this is that this is a cycle that goes around.
Okay.
So you only need this to get that started to get the first bromide and the
subsequent bromides can come from that.
And the actual product then ultimately is h plus came off here
of the ultimate product is the Alpha brominated acid.
Okay.
Uh,
I was hoping I'd get further than this.
I'm going to go,
well,
let's see.
Yeah,
I'll go,
uh,
just this slide.
So Alpha alkylation
we promised before that that the real advantage of having these,
uh,
carbon nuclear files is the possibility of putting an art group on there.
So,
um,
so you do this with,
with,
uh,
I have here.
So you use a base,
you get an analyte
okay?
From your ketone Aldehyde.
Okay.
And now this,
you react with something like methyl iodide,
so,
and electrophilic carbon sigma star.
Okay.
And you can make a new carbon carbon bond alpha.
So the same way we could put roll mean an Alpha or hydrogen and Alpha,
uh,
we can put a methyl in Alpha,
right?
But there's a problem here because we also have the possibility that could react
here.
So,
which nucleophile wins is the question.
Um,
I think I probably should let you go now and Wella go onto the resolve the
perils of Pauline and next time.
Okay.